right and i know that they're in japan i
think there's a lot of
pressure for businessmen to to socialize
as a group
and and work very late hours sometimes
all night
uh did you feel that pressure and then
how is it versus
the in the states i'm sure there's still
that same pressure but the hours are not
as long and
can you advise um if you're comfortable
if you don't want to talk about it
what it was like before you came to los
angeles
being a woman in that culture and then
coming here
and maybe you were more accepted yes
exactly so i feel much more freedom here
and much more opportunity here
and then um but the time
like you said the japanese worked until
midnight or so late but still i worked
around midnight because not at office
because of their time differences the
10 10 am in japan is 5 p.m here
so they started calling me around
6 p.m or something right so if they
have an emergency or urgent mother
they don't care the time so they called
me like midnight or
1am and they the first
word they said like what time is there
yeah did you feel pressure to
um be more like the men there or did
they respect the fact that you're still
a female
you mean in japan right when you were
coming up the ranks
um maybe in the entertainment industry
um i don't feel you know
there uh maybe
it's i'm not the typical japanese so
i don't care they're i'm female or male
so i'm a one person's uh
sure yeah but there
i don't i didn't feel the pressure
because i am the woman
um but i'm sure some of them
feel that way but i
if i were i have a next
you know life i want to be a man i don't
know
i'm you know i'm comfortable to being a
woman
sure and then here as well so of course
i feel more freedom here
and then we'll accept that as a woman
but
you know i enjoy being myself
if there was let's say someone at
university right now that
a woman who wants to be in business
whether international law entertainment
what would your advice be to her because
there may be pressures for her to be in
a certain mold
and you obviously broke out of that mold
and decided to be your own person
what would you tell that woman um
i think it takes time
to do something and like
i was on 20s i'm struggling so much and
then i
all the time asking my boss please give
me the first step
if you can give me the first step it's
really easy to
get the second step so i always thinking
the first step is the most difficult
things
and like the co-production things
there it was maybe the most difficult
part is to have the first project
as a producer and because nobody knows
wow wow in their co-production
industry and and then so
first of all i have to let them know
what is the wawa
is and if they understand what is wawa
is
the com project is coming to me
i don't need to look for it so
they're the most difficult things to
have a
first step or first basic
you know environment so
if they keep doing it someday they could
broke
their wall right so it sounds like
uh persistence but also patience yes at
the same time
okay but keep doing it like don't
give up right yeah so like
um when i was twenties i all the time
wanted to move to united states
and maybe because um
i want to work for united nations
in my university age and
even i changed my mind but still
i wanted to move to u.s because
my you know their relatives is worked so
well and for me it's really cool
and if i move to united states i want to
be the same thing
and then but there i enjoyed my job too
much
that's the reason i couldn't quit my job
and then
i couldn't leave my company and then
there
so i kept working it working for wawa
maybe their purpose changed
uh a little bit a little by little
on 20s i just want to go to u.s and to
do something but they
start enjoying my job um
los angeles is the center of
entertainment center of the contents
and i wanted to move to new york on my
20s but
maybe when i turned around 30s
i wanted to move to los angeles because
of the job
um so i had a purpose to move
here but still you know
i didn't have a chance to do it and i
enjoyed my job in tokyo
and i really enjoyed interviewing there
many people and and then
there one day my boss told me do you
have
interested going to los angeles and i
said yes
of surgery why not and then he said to
me
i didn't tell you why i
you know that he didn't tell me that
reason
but i already answered to him yes i'm
going to lose until
oh okay and then after he tell he told
me
wawa is going to open los angeles office
that's the reason
i asked you and of course
you